[Musique]
pour l'instant on ne sait rien on sait
qu'on a des chances on a préparé je sais
qu'il ya des artistes invités qui vont
être présents dont moi corneille va être
l'heure puis si je peux chanter une
chanson et corneille c'est sûr que mon
dieu ça va déjà être un rêve de réaliser
ça va être un spectacle incroyable puis
que oui j'ai une fébrilité certainement
mais c'est que du bonheur
on y donne en ce moment dolor c'est
diane et j'adore setec j'adore ça va
j'adore sa musique est tout et puis
sinon j'ai grandi avec qui charles
aznavour dans les oreilles je m'inspire
beaucoup de mon bagage
j'ai une vie assez mouvementée puis je
m'inspire de ça pour écrire mes chansons
je suis inspirée par l'amour également
des choses c'est sûr c'est sur ces soins
d'ailleurs je le dis dans toutes mes
entrevues
la france me manque c'est mes racines
la france a fait partie d'une des plus
belles parties de ma vie mon rêve est de
réussir ma carrière musicale au départ
au québec met ensuite en france